hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video hier befinden uns hier gerade
immer noch vor dem schloss genau wir
befinden uns ja heute und ich habe mir
gedacht wir haben ein basketball
gefunden wir haben zwei körper einen
kleinen korb und einen großen chor das
passt doch genau für eine basketball
channel das ganze wie folgt ablaufen ich
werde mit meinem partner
das hat jeder gehört wir haben im
basketball und sie wird auf den kopf
werfen ich werds thema auf den korb
werfen und wer am ende mehr punkte hat
hat quasi gewonnen ich muss den kleinen
köpfe größer als die deswegen nimmt sie
die kleinen kopf mit dem großen chor der
verlierer muss auf instagram und bild
vor dem schloss postler fall die
dramatischen worte wunder setzen von
wegen ja mich kotzt das alles an und ich
bin eigentlich ein bett geworfen einmal
getroffen
ich muss werfen nein nicht rein
ich freue mich immer noch hinten
klassiert sind bei der hälfte angelangt
sind alle werke ist immer so ein
bisschen zu weit links hatte ich nur das
warte ja das viel zu leicht zu null
das ist mir zu leicht fällt
es ist der neunte der zehnte der 83
kelly du musst treffen
die anspannung steigt meine damen und
herren
oder wieder nicht so da oben hin stellt
somit scheinen runter schmeißt oder so
kommst du darauf dass hier sind die
bilder die wir aufgenommen haben
irgendwie sowas in der richtung
sanierung schreiber bitte sehr geehrte
folgende folgenden brief leichtsinnig
immer die nette diese liebe in letzter
zeit war es für mich jedoch vermehrt
schwierig diese nur gespielte rolle auf
rechts
deswegen muss ich euch heute mitteilen
dass ich mich so im internet nicht mehr
geben möchte zum abschluss dann optisch
gefällt oder nicht komme werde ich in
nächster zeit kein blatt mehr vor den
mund nehmen und euch meine richtige
seite zeit
das ist jetzt quasi der komplette text
in den keller hier eingeschrieben hat
einen käufer ihrem instagram ansehen ich
verlegt das bild einfach mal der
beschreibung des foto wird gepostet
das war's von wieder meine damen und
herren wir haben jetzt wollt ihr die
basen deutschland aufgenommen wenn ihr
das bild sehen wollt habe ich einfach
mal ein link euch dazu oder zum
instagram von ihr oder so in die
beschreibung gepackt die channel ist
natürlich auch von den gewöhnen uns
beide sehr über eine bewertung freund
kelly zeigt auf dann demnächst ihre
richtige seite